madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue en
direct sur le plateau de la voie est
libre en bourgogne aujourd'hui je reçois
le député de la nièvre christian paul
bonjour christian paul le premier
signataire de la motion b en vue du
congrès du ps qui aura lieu du 4 au 7
juin prochain à poitiers l'émotion on
peut le rappeler un ce sont les textes
défendu en fait pour haut débit pour
définir la ligne politique du parti
cette année il y en a 4 dont la motion a
porté par jean christophe cambadélis
l'actuel premier secrétaire et la motion
b que vous incarnez donc christian paul
on va donc parler de vous du ps et des
idées que vous défendez à la maison je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez poser vos
questions directement à christian paul
via twitter via notre page facebook ou
sur notre site internet
il est comme le pape françois il va vous
surprendre vous verrez c'est votre avis
à le député dit frondeurs pascal cherki
qui parlait de ainsi de vous lorsque
vous avez été désigné comme le premier
signataire de cette notion b qui
rassemble donc les courants de la gauche
ce qu'on appelle les frondeurs vous vous
sentez des points communs avec le pape
est voilà moi je reste évidemment très
laïque dont dans mon engagement les
dombes et combat est d'ailleurs plus le
plus le temps passe et et moi je me
retrouve dans ce tableau fondeur que les
les journalistes pardonnez moi nous ont
parfois à coller parce que je défends
des idées claires je fais oui et puis
tout simplement je parle aussi de
rassembleur parce que c'est long je
danse congrès s'est pas de se diviser
c'est pas de se compter c'est de se
rassembler de chacun le fait à sa
manière moi je fais en faisant des
propositions je le fais en souhaitant
dans ce congrès socialiste qui doit être
un événement qui intéresse les français
je souhaite la clarté des idées et je
souhaite que la gauche avec françois
hollande président de la république
jusqu'en 2017 puisse réussir voilà donc
c'est pas c'est pas une attitude de de
critiques ou d'opposition savez je le
dis souvent il ya 80 de ce que nous
faisons dans ce que je dis aujourd'hui
il ya 90% de propositions il y à aussi
10 % d' alerte très sérieuse sur la
situation économique et aussi sur la
situation politique de la gauche qui
risque de ne pas être au 2e tour en
demie 17 voilà les raisons de mon combat
alors je ne sais pas je ne sais pas si
il y à là des points qui rapproche avec
avec le pad françois mais ceci dit je le
dis avec une totale modestie c'est un
pape dont l'itinéraire est regardé par
beaucoup à travers le monde voilà
de ce que j'entends vous n'êtes pas le
premier opposant aujourd'hui à françois
hollande ont scindé par messali je n'ai
jamais enfin c'est comment imaginez-vous
qu'un député socialiste il lui par des
électeurs qui ont souhaité en 2012 un
changement profond après les années
sarkozy qui ont été des années noires
pour beaucoup pour l'économie pour les
services publics et pour nos territoires
comment imaginez vous que je sois en
situation d'opposition je ne suis pas un
opposant je suis plutôt un proposant
mais je suis aussi exigeant vous êtes
apparu comme ça parce que là parce que
la lumière des médias et parfois de
nature à avoir un effet de loupe quand
sous la vème république
après deux ans d'exercice du pouvoir
nous disons au président de la
république attention il faudrait changer
non pas le cap pas le point d'arrivée
mais la manière dont on conduit la
politique faire en sorte que ce que nous
faisons soit un poids plus efficace et
plus juste
c'est suffisamment nouveau et inédit
pour qu'on nous traite parfois
d'opposants je ne suis pas un opposant
je souhaite vraiment que la gauche
réussisse au pouvoir parce que si la
gauche réussit au pouvoir ça signifiera
que la france va mieux or aujourd'hui la
france ne va pas bien c'est la raison
principale de mon combat est par
ailleurs le parti socialiste lui
pourrait aller beaucoup mieux il est
d'ailleurs depuis trois ans dans une
situation qui n'était pas écrite
d'avancé il n'y a pas de malédiction
mais depuis trois ans on voit bien parti
socialiste parle pas des militants sur
le terrain qui font leur travail qui se
sont engagés dans des élections locales
qui parfois ont été d'ailleurs battu pas
pour leur bilan local qui était bon mais
parce qu'au plan national ça n'allait
pas bien donc oui il c'est vrai au plan
national le parti socialiste depuis
trois ans n'a pas trouvé son rôle et sa
place alors est-ce que c'est pourquoi
c'est vous qui portez cette motion est
ce que c'est parce que vous n'êtes pas
un ancien ministre de françois hollande
donc c'est assez pratique justement il
vous n'allez pas le minage de nos pauses
en frontal quoi mais je pense que à la
veille de ce moment important pour nous
qui est un congrès c'est la seule fois
en cinq ans pendant tout le quinquennat
françois hollande que les militants
socialistes peuvent s'exprimer par leur
vote et reprendre en main le destin leur
parti c'est vrai qu'il ya eu la volonté
de dépasser les courants du parti
socialiste et faire appel à quelqu'un
qui avait plutôt l'image d'un
rassembleur voilà et c'est de cette
façon là que nous sommes progressivement
mis d'accord sur sur cette candidature à
la fois
dans le congrès est aussi pour incarner
une nouvelle majorité au sein du parti
socialiste rassembleur mais en même
temps vous venant vous incarnez quand
même la gauche on peut dire d'une des
partis socialistes ou jouent gros ce
garnement doit bien au delà non on ne
sait pas où vous savez si c'était elle
elle gauche aile gauche du parti
socialiste elle fait traditionnellement
20% et elle a son rôle pour animer le
débat d idées la situation est
suffisamment grave
je le rappelle trois défaites
consécutives consécutive défaite
électorale trois défaites électorales et
surtout une situation économique où on
voit bien que même quand il y a repris
ce n'est pas la sortie de la crise c'est
aujourd'hui un début de croissance une
croissance sans emploi et puis trois
défaites donc municipal élections
européennes et les xxièmes départemental
le front national qui s'installe
durablement qui progresse dans le
paysage politique français d abstention
massive à l'occasion de ces élections ça
ne peut pas laisser indifférent ça ne
peut pas laisser inertes des femmes et
des hommes de gauche qui se sont engagés
pour faire bouger les choses
authentiquement et qu'il ne souhaite pas
effectivement que progressivement la
gauche soient effacées dans le paysage
politique donc c'est vrai certains c'est
pour moi c'est une démarche aussi de
sursaut c'est pas une révolte gratuite
c'est une démarche de sursaut parce que
la gauche doit jouer son rôle alors
certains ont du mal à comprendre on va
voir où on a peut-être vu déjà quelques
tweets je vends donnait 2 de gens pour
moi les frondeurs sont contre productifs
ils alimentent le discours anti gauche
et anti hollande qu'on pense monsieur
paul et eric ajoute paul est un trade du
ps qui ne fait que critiquer son camp il
donne des points à l'extérieur mr
mélenchon et à la droite
oui mais lequel reste qu'on vous pourrez
ce sont des gens qui nient la voie
publique il faut se respecter il faut
pas se caricaturer moi je n'ai pas
conduit une démarche d'opposition
d'affaiblissement j'ai réagi avec des
dizaines de députés quand la gauche a
perdu les élections municipales et des
élections européennes il faut pas
inverser l'ordre des choses nous avons
considéré il ya un an nous avions un
devoir d' alerte pas une forme
d'opposition un devoir d' alerte pour
redresser le tir pour que la gauche
puisse se retrouvait alors que la
majorité depuis un nom s'est
progressivement rétrécit il ya eu c'est
vrai au sein des socialistes beaucoup de
doutes qui se sont exprimés
et d'autres partis qui étaient dans la
majorité l'ont quittée uni sont pas
rentrés donc franchement il faut il faut
mettre les choses dans le bon ordre et
donc moi je souhaite est évidemment que
les deux ans qui viennent
deux ans pendant lequel françois
hollande encore la possibilité de faire
de grandes et belles choses soient
pleinement utilisé parce que j'entends
bien voyez j'entendais encore à la main
qui a quelques jours disons françois
hollande ne fera plus rien mais c'est je
veux faire mentir cette prophétie moi je
souhaite que françois hollande au
contraire change de braquet que sur la
politique économique l'aspect fasse
davantage de soutien à l'investissement
bien ciblée sur les entreprises qui
veulent investir ou qui veulent
embaucher je souhaite en matière de
services publics on l'a beaucoup dit
après les événements du 11 janvier on
est vraiment un plan république qui
permettent aux français qu'ils soient
dans l'est dans les banlieues ou dans
les villages de se sentir partie
prenante de la république voilà mon
combat donc ce n'est pas un combat ce ne
sont pas des querelles médiocre ce sont
des propositions je crois de nature à la
fois à relever le pays est aussi d'abord
à relever le parti socialiste pour
compléter ce que disaient les
internautes karine jean luc mélenchon a
dit qu'il souhaitait votre votre
victoire et il a ajouté que ce serait
une motion de censure des militants
contre le pouvoir alors est-ce que du
coup je serai pas patalo président laïc
selon lui plus nos chouchous n'est pas
socialement j'enlève mon choix a
souhaité il ya quelques années quitter
le parti socialiste
moi je ne souhaite pas emprunter ce
chemin là je ne crois pas que ce soit un
chemin utile pour la gauche aujourd'hui
dans les deux ans qui viennent c'est au
sein du parti socialiste qu'il faut
faire sérieusement bouger les choses et
je ne crois pas à d'autres scénarios il
ya des pays où ces scénarios ont eu
toute leur place en grèce par exemple
avec avec syriza mais ce qui est bon
pour la grèce n'est pas forcément bon
pour la france on a vu par exemple cette
semaine également d'autres scénarios en
grande vente à chaque pays a sa
spécificité en matière politique et les
français aujourd'hui ils attendent que
la gauche au pouvoir les défendent c'est
ce qu'il sait ce qu'ils n'ont pas
suffisamment senti depuis trois ans ils
veulent que l'est quand les socialistes
sont au pouvoir ils les défendent
réellement ils veulent le sentier
veulent sentir en matière économique en
matière en matière sociale c'est sur ce
terrain là que nous devons nous battre
et
je ne suis pas moins un prophète de
catastrophe je ne pense que nous avons
encore la possibilité de réussir la
catastrophe elle viendrait si rien ne
change effectivement en 2010 at parce
que là en 2017 on le voit bien
aujourd'hui si le décrochage de notre
électorat se poursuit c'est pas moi qui
le provoque c'est la situation c'est
peut-être la faiblesse de certaines de
nos réponses le deuxième tour des
élections présidentielles à 6017 se fera
sans les socialistes moi je veux éviter
un nouveau 21 avril 2002 vous rappeler
le 21 avril 2002 alors que nous avions
pourtant avec lionel jospin a un bon
bilan la gauche n'était pas au deuxième
tour on l'a découvert
le dimanche après midi là trois ans
avant nous avons vraiment tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé j'invite les
socialistes à méditer cette idée il
reste deux ans est ce qu'on se cache
dans le fond de la tranchée en attendant
des jours meilleurs qui ne viendront pas
ou est-ce que franchement collectivement
on débat on dialogue on le fait devant
les français moi je pense que le congrès
du parti socialiste et de ce point de
vue merci de donner la parole ce matin
ça ne doit pas se faire à huis clos on
doit pas fermer les portes et des
fenêtres même frère et en même temps
là c'est un peu une critique à jean
christophe cambadélis et un car refuser
le débat public j'ai avec ruth série
mais en même temps est-ce qu'il n'a pas
raison finalement les rouages internes
du parti socialiste ça concerne les
militants du parti socialiste aux
protégés n'ont pas seulement parce que
pour moi le débat c'est pas le déballage
le débat c'est de montrer aux français
comment un grand parti démocratique
quand il est au pouvoir de continuer à
avoir une discussion sincère et sérieuse
et d'ailleurs je les ai vus dans le tour
de france que je fais en ce moment dans
beaucoup d'endroits il ya entre les
militants socialistes les élus les ceux
qui défendent les idées les miennes et
et ceux des autres celle des autres il y
à des débats de très bonne qualité et si
les français vous voyez ces débats comme
ils l'ont vu au moment des primeurs je
voulais sur 10 aurait sans doute une
meilleure image du parti socialiste
d'accord
on peut rappeler quand même que ce sont
les adhérents du ps oui mais au final ce
sont les socialistes qui décide dans un
congrès et c'est d'abord évidemment leur
choix c'est d'abord en conscience je
l'espère en totale liberté qu'ils se
détermineront mais c'est un événement
savez les primaires ont dépoussiéré la
vie politique d'ailleurs à droite on va
probablement faire aussi il faut que la
vie des partis soi ne soit pas enfermé
dans un bunker je crois que çà çà çà
acclimate l'idée que les partis ne
s'occupe pas des problèmes des français
sasa accrédite l'idée que les partis
politiques sont hors sol moi je le sais
pour pour vivre aussi cette réalité avec
des militants dans la nièvre dans le
morvan et et ailleurs maintenant dans ce
dans ce tour de france je vois des gens
qui ont envie de jouer ce rôle de
médiateur entre la société et le pouvoir
politique puisque aujourd'hui c'est la
gauche qui est au pouvoir est ce que les
militants socialistes peuvent jouer
réellement ce rôle là c'est vrai que
c'est difficile si le parti ne prend pas
à bras le corps les problèmes de la
société et c'est vrai et c'est pas à
être en dehors de mon rôle que de le
dire je considère que sur beaucoup de
questions importantes
le parti socialiste n'a pas pris
position ces dernières années je prends
deux ou trois exemples illustrés sur le
travail du dimanche et la loi macro
parti socialiste avait pris une position
il n'a pas défendu dans mystique sur la
loi renseignement qui a été adoptée
beaucoup d'incompréhension vis-à-vis de
vos lames et je vais répondre là le
parti choisit aucune position moi j'en
ai cru je veux je m'assume et je la
défendrai si vous m'interrogez mais on
n'en a pas pris sur les collectivités
locales sur la réforme fiscale qui était
un grand engagement de françois hollande
le parti socialiste n'a pas pris de
position et ne l'a pas défendu donc
comme vous voulez vous que les militants
socialistes
après trois ans aux responsabilités
n'est pas quand même un sentiment de
déception mais en 2012 nous avons levé
un espoir le discours du bourget était
un moment très important très entendus
par des français ils ont le sentiment
ensuite que les actes ne suivait pas et
moi je souhaite que le congrès n'en
watier il ya eu déjà eu des promesses ou
des engagements plus tôt qui n'ont pas
été suivies par des actes et ce que je
ne souhaite pas c'est qu'au congrès de
poitiers par l'habilité des uns ou des
autres et les textes qui ont été signés
sont parfois marquées par cette habileté
on est à nouveau des engagements par
exemple à faire la réforme fiscale et
que trois semaines après on nous dise
mais c'est pas possible on le fera pas
voilà et donc ce grand écart entre le
discours et les actes je pense qu'il
n'est pas bon pour la politique pour la
démocratie la fin d'une toute petite
parenthèse puisque vous entendez la
perche sur la loire renseignements école
on a eu quelques tweets et c'est vrai
que ça a beaucoup d'eux et on peut le
dire comme ça sur les réseaux sociaux à
propos de votre abstentions 1 sur 7 je
n'ai pas
voté contre et ça a été mal compris de
tweets pour ça qu'elle cohérence à
vouloir la clarté du ps tout en
s'abstenant sur la liberticide loi
renseignements ça c'est stéphane et puis
une autre est-ce que comment va le
sommeil de christian paul depuis sa
ferme abstentions vous savez
dans ce genre de situation
ne pas voter la loi c'est effectivement
ce que vous étiez pour une loi j'étais
favori alors je vais dire je vais partir
du fond et après on parlera du vôtre sur
le fond j'étais favorable et noir
enseignement parce que les menaces
terroristes utilisent aujourd'hui les
réseaux numériques chacun l'a compris et
il y a également à la disposition des
services de renseignement des
technologies nouvelles très intrusive
très sophistiqué qu'il faut absolument
encadré c'est pour ça que depuis des
mois je demandais avec beaucoup d'autres
qu'il y ait une loi qui encadre
l'activité des services de renseignement
c'est toi elle est venue au parlement ll
marque quelques avancées sur certains
points mais elle a surtout à mes yeux un
inconvénient qui est une menace de
caractère totalement inédit on appelle
cela des boîtes noires avec des
algorithmes c'est un peu technique mais
la réalité c'est que la totalité des
données de connexion des français fera
passer à la moulinette de ses
algorithmes sert de façon anonyme il ya
des garanties qui ont été donnés ces
garanties ne me paraissent pas suffisant
donc effectivement des baléares étaient
contraints alors parce que je souhaite
mener le dialogue avec le gouvernement
jusqu'au bout j'ai écrit il ya huit
jours à manuel valls m'a répondu en
début de semaine
je pense que cette lettre pourrait être
utilisée par les sénateurs pour
améliorer le texte ont la facilité ça
aurait été alors soin de voter la loi
beaucoup ont fait un don qui nous fait
là une très grande majorité les vrais
droite et gauche attend a été votée très
massivement à l'assemblée nationale et
je savais qu'il en serait ainsi il ya eu
effectivement quelques ventes contre
pour des raisons de principe que je
comprends tout à fait simplement étant
engagé sur ces questions de libertés
numériques depuis très longtemps je
souhaitais véritablement mener le
dialogue avec le gouvernement et avec
les associations qui militent pour les
libertés numériques jusqu'à l'adoption
de ce texte ou jusqu'au retrait ce que
je souhaite non pas de la loi mais du
des dispositifs sont les boîtes noires
voilà donc le nous sommes simplement en
première ligne je me gare tout à fait la
possibilité de voter contre ce texte à
la fin du parcours parlementaire si je
considère que nous n'avons pas obtenu
suffisamment voilà donc on peut pas me
reprocher à la fois 2 parfois d'aller un
peu trop loin dans la critique là je
suis sur une démarche de dialogue pas
facile pas facile parce que je savais
c'est pas évident de ne pas voter une
loi de cette importance là donc je le
fais en conscience pour aller au bout de
la discussion avec le gouvernement
suivra la taxe en deuxième lecture allez
renault à la motion b à ce congrès du ps
avec une question là qui m'arrive à
l'instant de shay ou trois ans que les
frondeurs échoue à infléchir la
politique quand je change la boue de
stratégie
mais c'est depuis depuis 2012 il nous
est arrivé évidemment de dans le
dialogue avec jean marc ayrault
notamment de marquer des divergences en
faisions hausse est vrai plutôt dans un
dialogue qui n'étaient pas publics ce
que vous appelez la fronde ça s'est
développé depuis un an à la suite des
défaites encore une fois je le redis
c'est pas ce ne sont pas nos positions
qui ont provoqué les défaites ce sont
les défaites qui ont rendu indispensable
à nos yeux des positions que nous avons
prises et ce devoir d'alep dont je
parlais alors changé de stratégie qu'est
ce que ça veut dire est ce que ça veut
dire rentrer dans le rang ne veut plus
rien dire alors que nous pensons qu'il
faut redresser le tir est ce que ça veut
dire au contraire quitter le parti
socialiste nous ne souhaitons pas je
pense que nous avons plutôt trouver au
fond le bon chemin en tout cas c'est une
ligne de crête c'est pas facile hein
c'est facile pour personne d'ailleurs en
ce moment d'abord pour les français et
puis ensuite pour ceux qui sont engagés
c'est pas facile parce que encore une
fois la situation
économique qui a été profondément
dégradées depuis la crise de 2008 les
gouvernements successifs n'ont pas
réussi à droite d'abord et à gauche
ensuite ça veut dire que les méthodes
traditionnelles ne suffisent pas donc il
faut aussi innové il faut changer de
façon de faire la politique économique
la façon dont on soutient les
entreprises dont on soutient la demande
dans ce pays ne résiste pas encore une
fois à l'épreuve de la crise donc où on
fait évoluer ces pelés moi je ne demande
pas au président de la république de se
renier je lui demande de changer en
profondeur la politique qui est menée et
de l'améliorer donc d'avoir des
résultats et de le faire aussi dans un
souci de justice parce que quand la
gauche est au pouvoir elle doit avoir
des résultats devant une empreinte
sociale en matière de pouvoir d'achat
note alors les talents de la motion à
qui est ce l on peut le dire du soutien
à la ligne actuelle 1 c'est comme ça que
vous la définissent et non je pense que
c'est hélas plus complexe je pense que
c'est un jean christophe cambadélis fait
aujourd'hui c'est vrai office de
paravent pour des gens qui ne pensent
pas tous la même chose voilà donc moi je
suis pour la clarté des idées et je
souhaite que qu'une fois le paravent
ne soit pas l'ultime protection de
beaucoup d'ambiguïtés en tout cas les
défenseurs de cette motion disent oui
leur bon il ya peut-être pas encore tout
à fait les résultats ça semble clair
mais il a fallu d'abord réduire les
déficits publics rétablir les comptes
publics qui avaient été aggravées vous
êtes un de ceux qui ont critiqué nicolas
sarkozy à ce propos et donc pour pour
récolter il faut semer donc est ce qu'il
ne faut pas laisser aussi du temps au
temps mais quelques retards c'est une
très belle formule de françois
mitterrand et à la veille du 10 mai j'y
suis sensible mais en économie on n'est
que de me faut parfois accéléré pour
mettre de l'engrais il faut il faut
mettre du carburant et et puis faut
mettre de l'énergie aussi qu'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis trois ans et il faut
il faut vraiment je crois l'expliqué un
instant c'est vrai les finances
publiques étaient naufragés naufragés
par les cadeaux fiscaux naufragés par la
crise et nous avons trouvé en arrivant
aux responsabilités nous avons trouvé
les finances publiques de la france avec
un endettement absolument considérable
jamais vu et des déficits qui était sans
limites est-ce qu'on a eu raison de
s'attaquer assad à blâmer mais je pose
qu'il fallait évidemment
remettre en ordre le pays je ne suis pas
de ceux qui pensent qu'il faut laisser
filer les déficits
je pense je pense néanmoins que nous
avions et nous avons encore des marges
de manoeuvre
qu'on appelle le pack de responsabilité
40 milliards d'euros on peut l'utiliser
beaucoup mieux au service de
l'investissement et de l'emploi et et on
soutient aussi à la la consommation des
français là on l'a mis exclusivement sur
des baisses de cotisations et de
fiscalité pour les entreprises sans
contrepartie ça c'est votre cheval de
bataille j'ai demandé chez land est
effectivement des tonnes
pour lequel nous avons interpellé
gouvernement parce qu'on a bien vu que
ça ne marchait pas et très franchement
là quand la reprise vient ailleurs en
europe notre angoisse aujourd'hui est
celle des chefs d'entreprise des
salariés et des français en général
qu'est ce que c'est c'est qu' il y ait
une reprise en europe et que la france
n'en profite pas donc c'est pour ça
qu'il faut remettre du carburant en
soutien à ceux qui veulent réellement
investir en soutien à ceux qui veulent
embaucher comme on fait ça mais mais
tout simplement en ayant non pas des
baisses aveugle de prélèvement ça a été
le cas là sur l'a40 dernière oui
clairement parce qu'il n'y a aucune
condition
ça n'est pas lié à l'investissement
ça n'est pas lié à l'embauché ça n'est
pas lié au coup de pouce qu'on peut
donner aux jeunes voyez en qu'est ce que
ça peut être des contreparties à des
baisses d'impôts et des baisses de
cotisations ça peut être évidemment de
l'investissement une entreprise a besoin
de se moderniser elle a pas forcément
les marges pour le faire les banques
n'aide pas forcément on l'aide
effectivement on donne ce coup de pouce
avec des baisses de fiscalité pour
permettre de le faire et on le fait
massivement ça peut être de l' embauche
ça peut être de dire voilà quand une
entreprise fait le choix de continuer à
produire en france de ne pas se
délocaliser et elle veut embaucher parce
qu'elle a un projet de développement de
l'entreprise on l'aide pour embaucher ça
peut être aussi d'aider les jeunes
voyagent avec discussion il ya deux
jours avec avec des jeunes qui me
disaient mais nous on a on a un très
grand
magasin
d'ameublement il ya là même à dijon
d'ailleurs et il disait mais quand ils
sont installés ils nous ont dit mais on
va on va donner un coup de pouce aux
jeunes de l'agglomération puis deux ans
après ou trois ans après ça ne vient pas
est bien une des contreparties qu on
pourrait appliquer à des grandes
entreprises comme celle là des grandes
entreprises de la distribution qu'on
aide aujourd'hui avec le cic le crédit à
l'investissement compétitivité emploi
c'est de donner un coup de pouce aux
jeunes de l'agglomération ce sont des
choses très simples et très concret et
la promesse de soutien à la jeunesse qui
est celle de françois hollande moi je
souhaite qu'elle s'incarne dans des des
décisions comme celle là donc baisser
les prélèvements des entreprises
pourquoi pas mais uniquement quand il ya
vraiment des contreparties pour
l'investissement pour l' embauche ou
pour les jeunes est-ce qu'il faut
arrêter
est ce que d'ailleurs l'état dans la
motion besson pour arrêter la politique
de l'offre mais il faut faire une
politique de l'offre avec des conditions
et des contreparties c'est pas au seul
vu du débat que nous avons c'est pas les
ceux qui veulent soutient les
entreprises et d'autres qui ne comprend
rien à l'entreprise c'est pas ça c'est
entre les seins trop bien évidemment je
suis ni contre les entreprises ni contre
les créateurs d'entreprises et on est
pas davantage contre les salariés
évidemment je suis pour que nous ayons
une économie qui retrouve sa prospérité
mais pour retrouver sa prospérité il a
sondé plusieurs façons de faire il ya
des vieilles recettes libérales
qui ont été utilisés en france et
ailleurs et dont je pense qu'elle ne
marche pas et il ya c'est vrai une façon
de mener la politique de soutien aux
entreprises plus volontariste plus
ciblés et c'est sans doute ce qui a
manqué au cours des deux ou trois
dernières années un mot sur leur
apporter c'est la journée de l'europe
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 9 mai
pour vous françois hollande n'a pas fait
assez pour réorienter la politique de
l'europe
je pense que le débat réclamé normale et
il est discours qu'avant si il est très
difficile et c'est vrai que nous
attendions de la gauche au pouvoir
qu'elle mène cette bataille en
particulier dans les premiers mois avec
davantage de vigueur parce que ce n'est
pas majoritaire on voit bien aujourd'hui
que l'allemagne a pris un poids
considérable et et que d'ailleurs là
l'inspiration libéral que je dénonçais
tout à l'heure c'est d'abord en europe
dans la au sein de la commission
européenne au sein des du gouvernement
de la droite allemande qu'on le voit
qu'on la voit cette inspiration se se
développer elle et oppressive pour les
peuples on l'a vu avec on l'a vu avec la
grèce on l'a vu avec un ces pays qui ont
dû mettre en place des politiques
d'austérité sur commande de l'union
européenne est donc aujourd'hui c'est
vrai les choses ont commencé à bouger en
europe lorsque la france d'ailleurs ya
contribué donc il faut engranger sa
l'euro est à une parité moins élevé ça
aide les exportations side quelques
grandes entreprises françaises la banque
centrale européenne nous le demandions
nous socialistes depuis des années à une
politique monétaire qui doit permettre
davantage de liquidités
pas pour faire démarrer l'inflation mais
pour soutenir également l'économie et il
y a un plan d'investissement qui a été
lancé par le président donc mais on voit
bien et c'est navrant je le dis aussi
moi le jour de l'europe c'est navrant
pour les européens convaincus de voir
que l'europe intervient trop tard pas
assez vite pas assez fort et que ce que
les citoyens européens vont garder de
cette période qui a commencé en 2008 une
perte la crise de crise financière on
sait que c'est encore la finance qui
continue d'avoir le pas sur l'économie
réelle et sur la politique et c'est vrai
que quand nous construisons l'europe
c'est vraiment pour faire contrepoids
c'est l'idée que nous avons l'europe les
libéraux veulent un grand marché nous
voulons que en europe la démocratie la
démocratie des peuples la démocratie des
institutions européennes qui doivent
être davantage dès qu'il doit être plus
démocratique puisse vraiment faire
contrepoids on voit bien dans l'est la
négociation par exemple du traité avec
commercial avec les états unis si
l'europe ne résiste pas et ne fait pas
contrepoids tôt ou tard les peuples
abandonneront est d'ailleurs la
principale
principal risque qui né de la réélection
de david cameron en beauté c'est vrai
c'est un référendum sur l'europe
l'europe peut commencer à se détricoter
et ça c'est ans c'est un risque auquel
il faut être particulièrement attentifs
hameau du plan république parce que vous
l'avez évoqué très très brièvement avant
qu'on fasse une pause
ce plan république donc c'est pour un
peu ce que vous appelez les territoires
oubliés donc c'est pressé les
territoires ruraux penser notamment à la
liesse bien sûr parce que je je je vis
et je travaille depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années dans un département la
nièvre et dans le morvan plus
précisément où je vois bien qu'il y a
progressivement un désengagement des
services publics même si nous avons
inventé des réponses alternatives
évidemment ne sommes pas restés les deux
pieds dans le même sabot mais dont trois
étaient moi je vous dit que ce n'est pas
un énième plan pour les
je pense que jusqu'à présent même si on
a fait un certain nombre de mesures un
peu de saupoudrage même si localement il
ya eu des des vraies intentions de
solutions différentes les maisons de
santé par exemple ce qu'on fait en
matière de numérique ce qu'on fait
également en matière scolaire de des
réseaux pédagogiques je crois que tout
ça est très important mais on a
l'impression d'être souvent des villages
gaulois appelé les astérix du monde
rural qui résistent ont effectivement à
allah à la prise de pouvoir des grandes
agglomérations sur les territoires
français donc il faut retrouver cet
équilibre là ça passe pas seulement
d'ailleurs par les services publics ça
passe aussi par l'économie évidemment
parce que s'il n'y a pas d'économie
rurale suffisamment vivante les
personnes intéressées personne ne veut
rester ou ne peut rester donc il faut
voir les choses globalement mais en tout
cas pour ce qui concerne le plan
république est née en quelques secondes
la république c'est une nouvelle
génération de services publics en
particulier dans le monde rural mais
aussi dans ces quartiers on a le
sentiment que la république née
des plus présente et facilement faisable
oui en redéployant aussi et puis en
alliant de l'imagination et en prenant
cette question au sérieux c'est une
question qui a été orpheline depuis des
années allez dans quinze secondes il va
être midi aura donc hausse interrompre
cette discussion là reprend juste après
le flash d'information jette un coup
d'oeil sur l'actualité régionale et
c'est avec elle liseré j'ai ce midi